okay hey treat male brand new graphic
banner for this week's hatred mail if
you are watching this is a new graphic
from Russell here's a reminder of what
hatred mail is the right of the people
to keep and bear hates shall not be
infringed Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom cob Betty
making an appearance in Russell's hatred
mail graphic if you were listening make
sure to check out this clip on YouTube
okay
this week's hatred mail has one of my
favorite and new terms I've never heard
this term before let's take a listen Wow
lmao David Pakman is a sorry ass of a
man boy don't he realized nobody gives a
flying [ __ ] about Russia and Trump Oh
David I get it now whatever takes the
spotlight off of DW s paying her
Pakistani spies posing at IT staff for
million dollars to feed the emails of
the Democratic Senate and Congress and
sell it to the highest bidder your fraud
and a joke ash recent charges are coming
Park man show program consists of
ignorance stupidity unlatch human beings
human beings not garbanzo beans not dark
red kidney beans not black beans but
human beans couldn't write this stuff if
I tried people who think that some
hatred males are fake who could possibly
come up with this stuff I could never
come up with something this crazy or
creative even if I tried
use hatred mail to create a better
situation for independent progressive
media hate free at forty hey tree at
forty is the coupon code which will save
you forty percent off of your membership
at david pakman.com slash membership